that Jimmy right here in front coach  came in here and he said this wasn't  Jimmy Butler today it was James Butler  because how much your name isn't James  woody but he talked about your maturity  well what do you think he was seeing  there that made him feel that way  I don't know I'm telling they put a lot  of confidence in me before the game I  put in a lot of work last night as well  as this morning but uh all the Norman it  was it was a team effort  I always go back to defense you know we  get stops we're taking over to the open  floor guys are making plays like Joe and  being you know whenever we're playing  like that guard like that we're such a  good team we definitely have to continue  to do it and know that on any given  night it's gonna be somebody's not we  have the group of guys that anybody can  get hot anybody could put the ball in  the basket you feed that hot ham